I think this is more of a matter of you  know Jerry can there against Izzy you're  getting there against a lot of people  he's just a tough cookie to figure out  he's just  he makes guys just kind of look kind of  basic or average or you know it they're  just there's something about Jared's  fighting style that guys just kind of  get outside what got them to the dance  and it creates kind of this boring  fighting style I'm not saying Jared's  boring I'm saying maybe because of his  pressure and his output you you it seems  to be your output's not as much even  though Sean Strickland was basically  trading one for one with him on the  output there but  it's just this chair Cannon air trance  he gets guys into this dance and it  doesn't make for the most exciting fight  so I think for Jerry can air Sean  strictly even though it was five rounds  um I had Jared win the fight I know Sean  Strickland says he was robbed I don't  think he was robbed